[Music]
can vogue's flowery pros hide their
brown nose well that sounds familiar
for its august cover story vogue
magazine declared dr jill biden a first
lady for all of us
and the article was uh the article was
so sugar-coated it should have come with
a shot of insulin
writer jonathan van meter who followed
biden on the road as she met with
students calls her a
joy multiplier joy multiplier is also my
stage name when i used to strip at
science fairs here's a line from the
piece
quote we have been through this enormous
collective trauma
and here's a calm experienced empathetic
president and here's a first lady who is
driven tireless
effortlessly popular but also someone
who reminds us of ourselves
it's true i too think of myself as a
doctor without ever going to med school
the cover line was pure corn syrup a
first lady for all of us
but we got our hands on a few that they
actually passed on
dr jill biden ron desantis wants to
destroy america
dr jill biden every president has a
woman behind them
reminding them that their president
dr jill biden the wife not the sister in
case joe is reading this
and speaking of alternate titles simon
schuster has revealed this week that
former national security adviser john
bolton
had a different idea for his book which
was titled the room where it happened
most intriguing title we had last year
was the room where it happened by john
bolt the original title for that book
ambassador bolton wanted to call it a
hard pounding
which was actually a quote from the duke
of wellington
after the battle of waterloo but we told
we told mr bolton that
some people might think that a hard
pounding had a sexual connotation
uh he told us that our minds were in the
gutter
sorry john they were right that's where
everyone's mind goes that book sounds
filthier than 50 shades of brian
kilmeade
but i still think they could have
compromised between hard pounding and
the room where it happened
like how about the room where the hard
pounding happened
or maybe the hard pounding in the room
where it happened
or maybe they should just have gone with
nobody mustache rides for free
cat um yeah you know what you you will
never be in vogue
because you're on you're you're on the
wrong tv show
yeah isn't that true that they treat
they treat people differently
that's not fair look i'll be okay um
but i i do want to talk about how john
bolton wanting to call that book
that is probably partially your fault
yeah all those
episodes of red-eye he was on yeah he
probably rubbed off on him a little bit
literally you're a joke literally
also i've heard he was the president of
reynolds president of run i next thing
you know is hard
pounding is his book and he's got his
new one coming out
called don't pull out the case for
keeping troops in iraq
good job nicely done all right casey you
i know you have a filthy mind
try to keep it clean uh what do you
think about the
the um the vogue cover in general well i
did accidentally google
the original title so don't do it yeah
yeah
um the vogue dr jill is a fellow
villanova alum
accomplished woman yes but i don't care
what you say you are lying to your face
if you don't think melania is the
best dressed first lady since jackie
kennedy
yeah that is absolutely that is true how
about you emily
what are your what's your take on a
vogue be
a hard pounding okay
are they separate i vote before a heart
pounding
girl so for evoke remember the magazine
sassy
yes jane pratt exactly and remember at
great america how you could get your
photo taken and then put on like the
cover
yeah so i did that when i was like eight
16 times and i thought
it was real i mean i was a cover girl i
had
that like a whole year every month every
month just that same photo of me
and i was so stoked and it was fake and
that's how i feel about this that i'm
sure everyone is stoked no hers is real
she's she's waiting to ride the box what
do you mean that's just sassy that's not
the same as you
let them have their victory lap because
when the rest of us look at that we see
exactly what's happening and we're not
taking it seriously we know to your
point that it's the brown nosing
happening and that
hard pounding by the way that is so my
mom
literally says all of these phrases like
from the renaissance era like
accurately like how it's meant to be
phrased
that means something totally opposite
now and my sisters and i are always like
oh gosh like she'll stay in public but
it has she's like
oh no this is what the you know the mail
carriers used to do
[Music]
i don't see the problem 69 is a year
literally literally it is a year and
every century
emily there's a 69. you know uh jimmy
there's a joke about your jacket and
heart pounding and being a porn director
but let's just get past that and say
something thoughtful to end this round
of debauchery
well there's a lot to be said first of
all your alternative titles the room
with a hard pounding
happen that's actually a presidential
memoir from the clinton years
nicely done he couldn't go with that
nicely and that is not the worst clinton
joke i could tell it is close but no
thank you the joe biden thing
um it first of all it is an absurd
double standard and at your point
melania is the superior first lady to
all other first ladies
but let's not knock her talents because
you know melania speaks what five
languages
yeah but jill biden speaks english and
joe
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she is she is the joe whisperer
there is no one in america no one in
america
is drinking harder every night than the
sign language interpreter for biden's
speeches
because he has to come up with words
that don't exist guys just slamming
drinks right now
that's absurd all right we've got so
much to go and we have to move quickly